hey Rob you know it'd be cool
what's that Chris I like this game that
just lets you and your buddies team up
and like you get a bunch of guns and you
can start tearing ass around the moon or
something and just romp or stop a whole
bunch of weird bad guys oh hell yeah
guess what what that game exists I know
it's cold ends the predating wall you
were what
come on man Borderlands you know like
for vault hunters all teaming up
together and getting all around the
countryside and just kicking a whole
bunch of ass
well destiny is just a three player
fireteam but you can kick up to six for
some big ol boss raids on the mother
move six nice I mean Borderlands takes
place on a moon but it's not like the
dusty old OneNote rock that actually
exists it's like this crazy lava spewing
ice frosted frontier moon with like
industry and infrastructure in that I
don't know sustainable economy or
something like that oh yeah cool I mean
that moon sounds pretty sweet and all
but what about like I don't know other
planets Earth Mars
I don't Venus it's just not Destiny's
got all those Chris Wow fly information
with your friend OHS and then plop down
on the planet take on all sorts of nasty
aliens like these guys those dudes not
even sure what the hell that is but you
get the idea
damn those things are nasty I mean I'd
be totally down to shoot their faces off
provided I could locate where their
faces were but what kind of weapons are
we talking about here
Borderlands has like a bajillion guns
you know they shoot bullets and lasers
and I don't know what else and a lot of
them actually packed elemental damage so
you can burn or corrode Electrify or
just try to freeze your enemies so then
you like shatter them t1000 style nice I
know right okay Destiny's got a decent
array of guns and some of them even have
that elemental zappiness that you were
talking about but it's actually the
class abilities that make you feel like
an interplanetary badass Oh Borderlands
got abilities too can each class learn
three different ones three
yeah I mean kinda alright let's stack
them up first up you got your golden
super gun how about some dual auto
aiming pistols Oh about a magic space
energy bomb I see your bomb and raise
you a damage absorbing boomerang shield
Oh about this indestructible dome shield
four words rubber duckie bounce stomp
about this Titanic area smash potion
twin drones that shoe heel beams and
deadly missiles yeah water land sounds
pretty cool breaths
Jesse sounds cool - I guess we should
what probably high five or something I
don't know is that that's too cliche
nope hey you know Borderlands has high
fives - Ukraine
[Music]